Now that the module has been created, we
can use it to bootstrap the application.
To bootstrap our app,
we need the attribute ng-app and
set it equal to the name of the module,
which is udsc MealsApp.
Using Yeomen to scaffold our
project has helped us out again,
because it automatically added
the code to bootstrap the app for us.
The code right here is
called the directive.
This is a mini preview on directives,
but they're awesome and very powerful.
When Angular loads, it scans your
HTML for this specific directive.
You can only use ng-app once and
it tells Angular two things.
First, this element
contains your application.
You can put this anywhere, but if we put
it on a div somewhere down in the page
then Angular will only be
loaded inside that div.
Second, it tells Angular to load
the Udsc MealsApp module and
all the components that it contains.
There are some other things to
be aware of when using ng-app.
Look in the instructor notes for
details.